[Música]
y llegamos directo hasta londres ahí ya
como le estaba conversando con luis
estaba nuestra corresponsal luisa puyol
y luisa la saludo muy buena tarde
primero por supuesto vamos a hablar de
esta ola de calor cuál es la situación
en el reino unido y como están las
temperaturas en londres sé que se siente
en este momento que tanto calor hace
luisa
tarde absolutamente caliente se siente
el sol en la piel casi rostizada hay
alerta en todo el país porque por
primera vez en la historia del reino
unido- se alcanzarán los 40 grados de
temperatura
especialmente en el suroeste de
inglaterra pero lejos de que las
temperaturas vayan a empezar a ceder en
las próximas horas va a pasar todo lo
contrario y van a seguir subiendo y se
prevé que mañana martes las temperaturas
récord aquí en el reino unido- serán de
43 grados de temperatura a esta hora en
londres tenemos 35 grados pero la
sensación térmica es muchísimo más alta
también se ha registrado temperaturas
récord para este país probablemente no
en otras naciones de américa latina pero
por ejemplo en galés se ha reportado 30
grados a las 11 de la mañana también en
escocia 26 y en irlanda del norte 24 las
altas temperaturas han hecho que el país
esté prácticamente paralizado se han
pedido cancelar las clases de los
colegios se les ha pedido a los
trabajadores que se queden elaborando
desde sus casas y que no se use el
sistema público de transporte porque ya
han sido cancelados servicios de tren y
de metro y se les ha pedido a las
personas que se mantengan dentro de sus
casas y por supuesto lo más hidratado
posible porque los consejos que están
dando los médicos son esas que se
mantengan hidratados todo lo que puedan
y por supuesto este es un campanazo de
alerta para tomar acciones lo más pronto
posible en esta emergencia climática que
está golpeando a todo el mundo y
lamentablemente luisa cómo están las
cosas si no ponemos de nuestra parte
tampoco los gobiernos pues esto va a
hacer con mayor seguridad en los meses
que vienen en los meses que vienen en
los años que vienen pero hablemos
también de otro punto principal de la
agenda del reino unido- aparte de esta
ola de calor que ya estábamos hablando
luisa y es la carrera digamos o para
suceder a la primer ministro británico
boris johnson quienes renunció ya hace
unos días atrás a cómo están las cosas
como está el proceso de votación y
además quien se perfila como el favorito
luisa
es una carrera que sigue subiendo de
temperatura esta noche será la tercera
ronda de eliminación entonces quedarán
cuatro candidatos en este momento a esta
hora y cinco son ellos los favoritos
reese's una primer dent listas que la
actual ministra de exteriores que me ve
y de know it on again hat entonces esta
noche quedarán cuatro candidatos se ha
cancelado un debate el último programado
para los finalistas porque listas y
richie zona que han cancelado porque las
acusaciones que se han hecho mutuas
durante los dos debates anteriores han
sido muy dañinas para el partido y de
sal la excusa que han entregado para
cancelar su participación entonces
probablemente el miércoles tendremos los
dos finalistas de los que saldrá el
nuevo primer ministro británico luego
estas dos personas se iniciarán una
agenda en el verano en agosto por todo
el país para tratar de convencer a los
votantes conservadores unas 180.000 unas
200.000 de 1000 personas que luego
tendrán que votar por correo físico y
entonces el 5 de septiembre se anuncia
quién es el nuevo premier británico y el
último día de boris johnson en downing
street será el 6 de septiembre entonces
johnson visitar a la reina isabel que es
la jefa de estado así anunciando que ha
terminado su gobierno y el nuevo primer
ministro iniciará labores ese mismo día
también visitando a la reina isabel